okay so the brand new trailer for Black
Panther wakanda forever is now here and
the latest look as well with Easter eggs
hidden details and a lot of things that
teased towards the plot throughout this
video we're going to be doing a big
breakdown on the new look whilst also
talking about some of the things
revealed about the movie at d23 the
people at the events were shown a
two-minute scene from the film and my
uncle sorry my uncle's friend filmed the
whole thing and sent it to me courtesy
of Henry spoilers so lots to talk about
and the movie itself is reportedly going
to be 2 hours and 41 minutes long this
makes it the second longest MCU movie
after Avengers end game so there's
plenty of time to tackle the passing of
t'challa the rise of Neymar and also the
new heir to the Black Panther mantle
we'll talk about who we think this is
later on but if you enjoy the video
please hit the thumbs up button and
don't forget to subscribe to the channel
for videos like this every day by the
way thank you for clicking this now
let's get into the trailer
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
ERS
[Music]
okay so the teaser begins with a shot
that was missing from the original
trailer and it has Sherry carry into
Charlie's helmet the song we can hear in
the background is Never Forget by Samba
the great and it sets the more battle
heavy theme for the first look whereas
last time featured a very emotional song
and No Woman No Cry this is slightly
more uplifting even though war is the
main focal point interwoven with these
shots of wakanda are ones with Neymar
and also his kingdom Neymar discusses
what it takes to be a great leader and
we've seen this trailer how he charges
headfirst into battle he's referred to
as the cool cool can which is the name
of a Feather serpent God pulling up the
wiki thread it has a clear and
distinctive head shape that I believe we
also see Neymar painting into the walls
he can hover in the air as well as move
at Great speeds which I'll talk more
about in just a bit now the initial
trailer of course massive simply scented
around the death of t'challa thus seeing
the character's funeral scene this loss
of course extends to the real world with
the passing of Chadwick Boseman who
sadly died before the production started
his character is rumored to die early on
in the movie without being basically two
trains of thoughts on it depending on
what leaks you read some say that he'll
be killed in a battle and that they'll
basically use a CGI body double of him
along with a replacement actor in The
Costume black panther of course wears a
mask covering his entire face so they
can quite easily do this however other
Reports say that he'll die due to an
unknown illness which will time more in
with Chadwick's death due to the actor
sadly passing away because of cancer
Dorothy Steele also sadly died after
production wrapped on this film and she
will be playing the merchant tribe
leader for one last time now Ramon there
is of course the queen and she's also
the one on the throne eagle-eyed viewers
might spot that there's a large piece of
vibranium on the throne armrest and
we'll talk about how the war for this
element could come into play later on in
the video we know that this throne room
will be flooded in the movie and that
the Dora melange will also stand in this
at one point possibly paying tribute to
t'challa huge shout outs to Eric Voss
and you rock stars for translating the
writing on the wall here and it spells
out in power t'challa our hero and honor
and lastly forever we've already had the
shot where the throne room seems to be
on fire and this might be a moment in
which Suri travels into the ancestral
plane got a lot of Vibes of when
killmonger ordered the herb garden to be
burned and due the way the Flames shoot
up the columns I think this might be
similar the funeral is a big event in
which people wear all white instead of
black the black panther is of course a
symbol of power in the nation and
whereas black and mean morning in other
countries in the wakandan world it means
strength even the Dora milaje wear white
instead of red and the funeral scene has
seen more of a celebration of life
rather than the grief of losing someone
during Civil War t'challa told the Black
Widow how the wakandans view death and
why it's not an end in my culture death
it's not the end as we know from the
first film when a wakandan dies they
pass into the ancestral plane where they
can be with the rest of their kin I can
imagine that we will end up traveling
there at some point in the movie when a
character becomes a black panther but
I'm expecting to see killmonger instead
of t'challa shuri will be carrying the
helmet of t'challa I think she's going
to be the person who ends up donning the
mantle come the end of the film as the
crowd dances away we can catch a statue
of the first black panther bashenga and
also the head of best in front of him
Bast could be spotted during Thor 11
Thunder and whether the God shows or
Pierre remains to be seen I'm sure he
also crosses her arms in the wakanda
sign hinting to how the kingdoms will be
uniting against this big threat now
Neymar is going to play a big part in
the film and we know from the first
trailer that we're gonna see his birth
all the way up to him leading his
kingdom the rise of this was teased all
the way back in Avengers end game when
akoye talked about underwater
earthquakes however according to Daniel
rbk it'll be Lake Bell's character who
causes the kingdom to awaken there are
minor cuts of ships at its see as well
as an expedition with divers and deep
sea suits and these will apparently be
what awakens the king although the
comics have had his kingdom as Atlantis
you know now that it will in fact be to
Loken that he rules over obviously
Aquaman is now a billion dollar
franchise for DC and due to the
characters being pretty similar I think
Marvel have shifted things over to this
instead of Atlantis so the atlantians
will now be tele Canyons rather than
what's in the source material they are
also changing up Neymar's origin
slightly and hello can seems like it's
far more traditional rather than the
technology-based city that it is in the
comics it's complete with Mayan
architecture and this extends all the
way to the Shoreline with their temples
on the beaches Neymar's costume will be
in line with how it's in the comics and
he will also have wings on his feet to
help him glide through the water and air
as a character Neymar was introduced all
the way back in 1939 before Marvel had
even been founded he debuted in the
motion pictures funny weekly issue 1
where we watched Ernest Shackleton on a
deep sea Voyage similar to what could be
happening with Lake Bell along the way
he and it Neymar and he ended up
fighting against the Nazis in World War
II after German divers were discovered
near Atlantis he fought alongside
Captain America and the original Human
Torch but obviously they're not going to
have that backstory in the MCU now he
has fought against the Fantastic Four
and he's normally an anti-hero that has
no problems working with and against the
good guys I can't see him being brought
in with a Fantastic Four in the future
and in the comics he's a major Sue storm
simp that could end up sliding in the
a38 universe now she's officially a
single mother there are you gonna get
wetter you know he's also been a member
of the Illuminati the illumawati but the
group was pretty crap and they ended up
failing reminds me of a group in Another
Universe now Neymar is also a mutant and
it looks like they might bring that
across to the movie as well we can see
from the other Tallow Canyons that they
have blue skin and have to wear masks
when they're on the surface Neymar
doesn't have to and he also doesn't
carry the blue skin that they do mutants
have been slowly popping up in the MC
with is Marvel Mr Immortal and elegila
and it's likely that they're going to
bring him in as one too it looks like
his mother may be human which is why she
doesn't have the blue skin either in the
comics he was half human as well so
they're probably going to be carrying
that across also with the masks thing
this was shut during the middle of the
pandemic so it is clever that they had
the masks Incorporated in the costumes
we see this at the UN with those that
follow Amanda and also the SWAT team
members at one point in the trailer we
see him in a full headdress the skull of
which looks like it belongs to a giant
sea serpent again tying back to the idea
by imbaku the two trailers we've seen
show Namor looking over him you'll love
this so potentially this could be linked
to how he or his lineage gained the
crown either way the temples and sea
life are all pulled into the location of
flesh out this undercover world that's
under the sea and under the siege of
wakanda potentially
God
killing him will risk Eternal War now
the war between wakanda and Atlantis was
a big thing in the comics I know it's
still Elkins but when referring to the
comics I'm just gonna use Atlantis but
yeah that's who I mean if we're talking
live action now they have had many
face-offs and during the events of
Avengers vs X-Men Neymar arrived at
wakanda to free a prisoner trapped there
he swamped the Golden City with a
gigantic tidal wave and though Tempest
died down this wasn't forgotten by
t'challa war was declared on Atlantis
and they've gone back and forth several
times with name or even telling Thanos
that an infinity stone was there just so
he'd attack it I'm back in narrates the
story of Namor and we can see what
appears to be War supplies being flown
into his home in the mountains due to
them being so high up I'm guessing that
this is where the wakandans retreat to
after the kingdom is flooded because
it's unlikely that a tidal wave would be
able to go that high also due to the
temperature it might be more difficult
for the fish people to fight there
because they're heavily reliant on water
and would likely freeze to death also
fish people might be a bit racist so if
it is I apologize I take accountability
I hear you I grow now though killing
Neymar could cause Eternal War he
clearly doesn't care about killing the
wakandans and we can see him attacking
the throne room directly with remander
and Riri inside now Riri Williams is a
big part of the teaser and we get
several shots of her flying through the
air similar to Tony's First Flight all
the way back in the first Iron Man her
boots also come together before she
flies off into the night and this is
similar to Tony traveling into space
during the opening of infinity War Riri
is from Chicago and the car that we see
a split second shut up actually has an
Illinois license plate on it making me
think that this links back to hair the
spear is also used to carve and do
tricks in the road similar how akoye did
it in the first Black Panther movie this
car also appears on the bridge flip
turned upside down like my homie Will
Smith I'm guessing that the big battle
that happens here with a fish with the
people
um is just tied into this scene ariri
Williams debuted all the way back in
Invincible Iron Man vol 3 Issue 7 and
he's gonna be a big character going
forward in the future of the MCU she is
getting her own Disney plus series and
it's likely that this movie is going to
be setting things up for that and the
comics Riri is a genius that gained
early admission to MIT though wakanda
may have created a program for students
as part of their un dealings her best
friend and stepfather were killed in a
drive-by out in Chicago which is where
she's from making me think she's being
brought over to wakanda as part of some
program potentially the show could give
us her full origin story but we'll have
to see where they go with it when it
eventually releases and the comics she
built her own suit of armor using
outdated Iron Man parts and also stolen
bits from MIT this led to security
trying to confront her only for her to
escape in her model one suit similar to
Tony's Mark 1. the movie seems to be
changing this up quite a bit as it
appears like she's using parts of a car
we also see that she has a diamond-like
Arc Reactor that Tony used in endgame so
potentially she ended up getting this
from the compound or after he handed it
over to cap colleagues have shown what
her suit looks like and it reminds me a
lot of a Beetleborg or one of the suits
a Power Ranger would wear now she's very
much gonna be trying to carry on Tony's
Legacy and his iron heart which surely
you can't be serious
[Music]
thank you
show them
Who We Are
[Music]
now we get a quick shot of reminder
shouting at the UN and this scene was
shown in Fallout d23 the first Black
Panther movie ended with t'challa
opening up about what wakanda really was
unless I think that Riri might have been
brought into it because of this
obviously they went to the basketball
court in America and it's like that she
might have been picked up in something
like this but that's just a theory time
that I'll not get into but the next part
of the video though I want to discuss
what was shown at d23 and it basically
centers around how the UN was annoyed
that they hadn't actually been sharing
all their resources because they'd held
back vibranium they worry that vibranium
could be manufactured into a weapon of
mass destruction and that it can be used
to elevate certain armies above others
this could end up tying in with the
upcoming arm Awards film which has now
been upgraded from a Disney Plus show
into a full-blown movie you know that
ironheart is gonna feature in that as
well now and she will of course be
making her debut in this film therefore
the vibranium plot could time with that
and raimonda makes it clear that though
they open things up it was always the
policy to never trade vibranium she says
this isn't because of of the potential
dangers of vibranium but because of the
potential dangers of you well well us
now from here we cut to a scene in the
trailer which shows a vibranium lab
being infiltrated by a SWAT team whilst
this is going on Roman narrates how the
UN preaches Civility and appears to be
friendly but that they secretly whisper
about gaining the precious element He
says the king is dead black panther is
no more but they still have their
protectors the SWAT team then open up
what I think is the Vault I don't know
mate someone's head was in the way and
at this point the Dora milaje arrived
and a scientist reveals herself to also
be a member this is Michaela Cole who
will be playing an acre in the movie she
was shown in the first trailer but just
an extra bit of info for the scientist
reveal now in the comics she was part of
the Dora melange but she ended up
leaving in order to form a group called
The Midnight Angels the doors to the you
and then open and the Dora melange
scored the captured SWAT team in the
middle Hall where they place them on
their knees from here it's segued in the
trailer that was shown at the event and
this had a couple of new shots now as
for who is in the Black Panther role I
think if we look at the comics then it's
likely going to be Sherry she ended up
taking over at one point and with her
being the next in line it makes sense
that things would pass to her as well
though funko's leaked for the film and
the Black Panther one gave us a slightly
better look than what we get at the end
of the trailer if by better luck you
mean that their heads are massive either
way pay close attention to the dots on
the forehead and I think that this gives
us a very clear indicator these dots are
what shuri also does when she's at the
funeral and therefore I think that it's
sending to us that it's definitely her
however it could also be an Ikea who the
first trailer opened up on this was then
coupled with a closing shot of the Black
Panther and it could have been the
biggest hint that she's in fact in the
suit however I think they're
deliberately keeping things ambiguous
because there will be multiple people
who take on the role if you look at the
marketing for the movie they're not
really pushing one character per se as
the lead therefore I think that several
people willed on the mantle the suits
themselves don't need person in it to
have the herb abilities as they're just
made out of vibranium Therefore several
people can take it up without too much
difficulty now it is possible that shuri
could create a synthetic herb but ever
had to put my money on who I think is
wearing the suit I think it's going to
be several people rather than just the
one however she will be the main one and
ensuri that the legend gets continued
anyway that ends the trailer and the
movie is dropping very very soon I am
excited to see what they do with it I
feel like the film has had a major
uphill battle due to losing its main
character however it seems like they're
really using that to celebrate the
legacy of Chadwick Boseman whilst also
delivering a heart-wrenching story about
war every time I see this film I'm more
and more impressed by it and the cast
really seem like they're giving their
all very excited to see when it drops in
November and obviously I'd love to hear
your thoughts on the teaser below we are
in a competition right now giving away
three copies of dollar and thunder on
the 15th of October and all you have to
do to be on the chance of winning is
like the video make sure you subscribe
with notifications on and drop a comment
below with your thoughts on the episode
we bake the comments at random at the
end of the month and the winners of the
last one are on screen right now save
that to you message me on Twitter at
heavy spoilers if you want something
else to watch make sure you check out
one of our videos on screen right now
which I've put it up for you go click it
because I need the money if not well
I'll never speak to you again uh but
yeah I hope I hope to see you soon you
take care yourself peace